what i thought we'd do to kind of like
you know kind of liven you up right at
the top is find out what you guys would
like to hear a rap about and then
i'm going to do a rap about it and yeah
you bought your tickets and we can lock
that door so this is what's happening
everyone think of a word topic or phrase
we'll divide them up into segments we'll
get five suggestions if you are in the
first three rows what would you like a
wrap about
okay
the rest of the audience is completely
tuned out at this point which is
probably a good thing because the front
two rows combined to come up with the
day in the life of a transgender eunuch
in staten island
yeah that's your responsibility second
second row okay
um
guys on this side you had a real
in-depth conversation what would you
like a wrap of that
i would love to know that's why i'm
asking a question
inspired by all of you guys high school
friends that swing dance
high school swingers
okay
you can't see where every time you talk
you emphasize with like that flip it's
amazing just like i'll have the eggs
yeah
so people people on this sniper at the
back what would you like to wrap about
yes
i am the leader of an online cannibal
forum high school swingers a transgender
eunuch in staten island
and let's come to the kind of middle
the middle
thank you very much thank you and then
we'll come to the back of the room what
would you guys like a rap about
ethical non-monogamy okay so i heard
losing your virginity and then but what
did you say
ethical non-monogamy
okay
yeah i feel like we're in brooklyn with
all these suggestions this is wild
okay
so
if i may have your attention class
thank you the suggestions are at
[Music]
transgender unique in staten island
ethical non-monogamy and losing your
virginity maybe high school swingers
a model in the metaverse and our one
from over here was your one which was
the leader of an online cannibal forum
okay
yeah those are some great suggestions
and this lovely people is going to be a
freestyle rap that's the right move on
the spot based entirely on those
suggestions and do not worry i'll not be
anyone here atrociously embarrassingly
toe colourly badger expecting a
privately educated middle-class white
boy to be
if we can drop that beat good sir let's
uh have some fun nice and you'll know
the beat
[Music]
jump on the beat then again let me log
on
log in for the reddit check it out it's
what i'm talking about i can run a whole
community out of my house in my bedroom
me i'm my best mates cannibal 69 yeah
aligned with those dates people like oh
i'm assuming cannibals love to eat the
flesh of the human that's true it's how
we do if you step too close then i
consume you take a knife and a fork no
need to talk i just stab it through your
eyes out on stalks and then i post
pictures post some memes i like
everybody logging unsubscribe to me on
my screen they're like we love you dude
you're on the forum for the video on
youtube if i look tasty might befringer
take you out to staten island
transgender but let me look at this
never so appalled transgender but no
genitals cause you're a eunuch it means
removing balls if you've seen game of
thrones it makes sense to you yeah paris
we ain't got nothing down there staten
island a good area now probably it's
kind of tough never even been moving
over here feeling kind of obscene but i
get knocked down censored on facebook
they want to distract us don't want us
to look they're like higher mark we're
trying to do better we'll rename our
company
did that take the bad news away oh look
at the model and how she says
[Music]
[Music]
what's wrong that i hold ah this is
oliver's ah who gives a [ __ ] will go to
the car he on the truck could start
mixing it up blind swinging i don't like
oliver's girlfriend because she's
hanging but that's fine by the way my
age in the rap i'm 16 so lose virginity
at the back seat of the car do i feel
nervous yeah premature ejaculation i
serve this it happens a lot when it's
your first time my girlfriend yeah she
really doesn't mind she doesn't get
upset doesn't stop in front
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before no danger he's like sure chris
you can [ __ ] any stranger and i'll be
like dope so i'll go and find him and
[ __ ] a transgender eunuch in staten
island
[Applause]
[Music]
you